I mean thinking most fascinating about
this whole subject is is something that
problems it quickly gets very technical
but but there's a there's some there's
there's an area of mathematics which is
known as representation theory and from
one way of thinking and it is thinking
about it is in terms of what are what
physicists often call symmetries so so
for instance one of the basic facts
about the laws of nature is that they're
they're they're symmetric laws of nature
are the same at you know if you move if
you move in any direction or you move in
time back and forth the laws of physics
don't change if you rotate things around
and three dimensions laws of physics
don't change and so so these so-called
symmetries and and these these
symmetries have very important physical
implications so friends the fact that
the laws of physics don't change as if
you change your if you move in time has
the physical implication that there's
this thing called energy and energy is
conserved and the same thing in the and
that the fact that laws of physics don't
change if you move back and forth in
different directions in space implies
that there's a something called momentum
and momentum is conserved and doesn't
change in as you move as you evolve in
time and so so these very very
fundamental facts about physics are kind
of deeply grounded in the symmetries of
of nature and so to a mathematician this
this this question is is a question
about what we call about groups and
representations of these groups so if
you go into any math department and look
at what they're doing you'll see that
you know that a lot of a lot of people
and different kinds of mathematics are
studying different structures which are
also called groups and they're often
studying later called representations of
these groups so even people studying num
number theory kind of abstract things
about about prime numbers or something
they're also studying groups and certain
representations these groups so there's
kind of a to the extent that mathematics
has a kind of unifying theme and a
unifying principle which shows up in
different areas of mathematics
it's about this retinas these
representations a representation theory
and the thing I most strike with most
anything as most tracks me about physics
most
to be about it is that if you look at
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics
initially looks like a very odd
structure it doesn't it's not something
we have any kind of to ative
understanding of it doesn't look like
you know like what the way we're used to
thinking about physics based on an
everyday experience but if you look at
the mathematical structure and the basic
structures of quantum mechanics they're
exactly the structures that show up in
this theory in this theory of
representations so there's a kind of a
deep relation between math and physics
which is what it was
surrounding this whole notion of
symmetries and representations of
symmetries so that so that's one thing
that's always fascinated me and then and
my own research my own inner interest is
is in kind of developing - taking a lot
that's been learned in mathematics
there's a lot that's been learned in
mathematics over the years about how to
think about representations and how to
construct them and how to work with them
some of it has made its way into physics
have been used in physics and was been
used in physics since the early days of
quantum mechanics and so friends is one
of the great kind of to the extent
there's a kind of hero of this book I
wrote about this it's a mathematician
called the Hermann vile who was a
special who kind of was one of the first
people to understand how quantum
mechanics worked and to understand the
relation to representations but but
anyway I think there's still a lot to be
learned in that way and raised
specifically the so called standard
model has this group of symmetries which
is called a gauge symmetry and it's an
infinite eventual group and the standard
kind of physics conjecture or
understanding of the representations of
this group is that there's is that that
should not be an interesting question
there should only be a trivial
representation of this group but anyway
my gesture is that there's there's
actually a much more interesting
question there and in pursuing that you
can pursuing this question of how do you
deal with the with the gauge symmetry of
this theory and in terms of using ideas
from representation theory that are um
that are more well-known in mathematics
that haven't been used in physics before
that you can actually get somewhere so
that's maybe a bit too technical but
that's about as good as I can do with